Sarah I will start with you you've been
working this story all day in fact
you've been working this story for weeks
it's been a big existential question out
there tell us the latest today so today
after all of the many months of rumors
that you and I have chased this is the
first time we've heard from sources
definitively that Goldman Sachs is
working with Twitter to deal with
incoming interest and have sort of these
informal conversations with bitters that
could turn into something more formal so
David sales first sales force versus
alphabet flash goggle what do you see
Twitter getting out of one versus the
other and what do they get out of
Twitter well it's quite different in the
case of the two different companies
obviously in many ways Google probably
could be said to be the company that
most could benefit from Twitter if they
were capable of using it properly once
they owned it but they need a social
system they need another way of
connecting with people of interacting
with people as BOTS and other systems
that they really don't have a play in
our become more and more important I
think that's why they announced the aloe
messaging service this week Twitter
could help them there it's just very
expensive on in the case of Salesforce
it's a much more of a kind of from left
field idea that a enterprise technology
company that's really been trying to
move into being sort of the de facto
leader in cloud-based enterprise
software would want to own what is more
or less a consumer service but I think
from the standpoint of Marc Benioff who
I happen to know quite well you know
anything that really draws more
attention to the company and helps
underscore their ambition to be a multi
you know service provider to a lot of
different kinds of companies including
marketers could be a plus and I think
you know it would really put sales force
on the map in the kind of common
parlance in a way they never have been
before and that might be worth a lot of
money for for Salesforce they certainly
didn't shy away from bidding for
LinkedIn and Marc Benioff told that to
us a couple of weeks ago you know he
wanted you to do the deal but you can't
win them all interestingly also sales
forces chief
Janelle evangelist Vala Afshar tweeted
this this morning why Twitter one
Personal Learning Network to the best
real-time content-rich news 3
democratized intelligence for great
place to promote others Sarah what do
you make of this I think somebody
internally got excited maybe he doesn't
know exactly direct details about a bid
or anything like that in fact we haven't
heard that there is a solid bid from
anyone right now I I think Salesforce
has always sort of promoted social
selling using Twitter there's a blog
post in 2014 where they said get out
there make relationships with people on
Twitter that you want to sell to make it
part of your your strategy and so maybe
a sale this Salesforce employee got
excited by the reports and said you know
why makes sense for them so let's talk
about what's actually happening within
Twitter I spoke to Eve Williams co
founder of twitter who is on the board
who had this to say to me when I asked
him about whether he wants to sell the
company just a couple of weeks ago take
a listen my faith is high and Jack is
fully supported supported jacks and do
you see and look I don't you know you
can only go so far but we've seen a lot
of M&A do you see Twitter remaining an
independent company no comment on that
and we're we're in a strong position
right now I think and you know as a
board member we have to consider the the
right options interesting that no
comment became a comment that drove the
stock up